l' équilibre budgétaire un clivage bien
clair entre les libéraux et les
conservateurs notre plateforme
conservatrice est plein de mesures
concrètes qui vont aider les familles
canadiennes à épargner et à planifier un
dossier promet un retour à l'équilibré
budgétaire d'ici cinq ans et ce malgré
69 nouvelles mesures qui coûteront près
de 49 milliards de dollars les nouvelles
mesures qui s'ajoutent aux déficits déjà
en place
c'est essentiel quand un gouvernement
qui arrêtent emprunter l'argent des
contribuables de la future prend
contribuables et payer plus en plus
d'argent pour l'intérêt sur le dac pour
y arriver
les conservateurs ont déjà annoncé
qu'ils allaient couper l'aide étrangère
de 25% et les subventions grandes
entreprises
mais à elles seules ces deux promesses
ne suffiront pas équilibrer le budget
les conservateurs veulent donc ralentir
les dépenses en infrastructures le même
montant sera investi mais en 15 ans et
non 12 comme les libéraux l'avaient
promis une économie de plus de 18
milliards de dollars au cours des cinq
prochaines années on va à garantir tous
les projets qui sont déjà a commencé
qu'il ya déjà eu une entente entre les
différents niveaux de gouvernement à
gauche il veut aussi limiter les
dépenses de fonctionnement de l'état
sans toutefois couper des postes dans la
fonction publique une économie de plus
de 14 milliards de dollars
les conservateurs veulent ou s'ils mieux
lutter contre l'évasion fiscale
il pense pouvoir récupérer près de 11
milliards de dollars
il compte aussi mettre en oeuvre un
impôt de 3 % sur les géants du web
une mesure qui ressemble à celle des
libéraux par contre les conservateurs ne
veulent pas taxer les plateformes comme
netflix ramasse les milliards de
l'économie de canet faut que chef
libéral justin trudeau le plan des
conservateurs est synonyme d'austérité
et de compression parce qu'ils veulent
pas que les gens voient à quel point ces
53 millions de milliards de dollars de
coupure qui s'attend qui vont infliger
sur les canadiens les conservateurs ont
aussi profité du dépôt de leur cadre
financier pour annoncer qu'ils ont
l'intention d'interdire tout voyage dans
des zones à haut risque de terrorisme
à dix jours de l'élection les électeurs
ont maintenant entre
- les plans de tous les partis pour
prendre leur décision il suffit de bain
sont choisis radio canada delta en
colombie-britannique